AR-15 ASSAULT RIFLES AND
HUNDREDS OF ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION.
>> Bret: STEVE HARRIGAN LIVE
IN PARKLAND.
THANKS.
TONIGHT THE WORLD IS MOURNING
THE LOSS OF ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE IN HISTORY.
THE REVEREND BILLY GRAHAM DIED
AT HIS NORTH CAROLINA HOME THIS
MORNING.
HE WAS 99.
DURING MOST OF THOSE YEARS,
GRAHAM SPREAD THE GOSPEL TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
IN PERSON AND ALMOST 200
HE WAS A PASTOR TO THE WORLD AND
A PASTOR TO PRESIDENTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED TODAY:
"THE GREAT BILLY GRAHAM IS DEAD.
THERE WAS NOBODY LIKE HIM! HE
WILL BE MISSED BY CHRISTIANS AND
ALL RELIGIONS.
A VERY SPECIAL MAN."
>> JESUS SAID THERE IS TWO ROADS
>> JESUS SAID THERE IS TWO ROAD
ROADS.
>> FITTING FOR A MAN WHO TOUCHED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS WITH THIS
MESSAGE OF HOPE AND FAITH.
>> FOLLOWED JESUS.
LET HIM LEAD YOU HOME.
CONDOLENCES FOR THE PASSING OF
BILLY GRAHAM HAVE BEEN JUST AS
HEARTFELT.
>> WE REMEMBER REVEREND GRAHAM
AND KEEP HIS FAMILY IN OUR
HEARTS, WE CONTINUE THIS WORK.
>> Bret: GRAHAM PREACHED TWO
MORE PEOPLE THAN ANYONE.
>> CHRISTIANITY IS NOT A WHITE
MAN'S RELIGION.
DON'T LET ANYONE TELL YOU IT IS
WHITE OR BLACK.
CHRIST BELONGS TO ALL PEOPLE.
>> Bret: A MAN OF GOD HUMBLED
BY THE FELLOWSHIP THAT SHAPED
AND EMBRACED HIM, CALLED BY SOME
THE PROTESTANT POPE.
THE WORLD WAS HIS PULPIT.
THE REVEREND BILLY GRAHAM SAID
HE FIRST FELT THE SPIRIT AT AGE
16 AFTER HEARING AN EVANGELIST
PREACHED.
SOON AFTER, LEAVING HIS FAMILY'S
DAIRY FARM FOR BIBLE COLLEGE IN
FLORIDA WHERE HE STARTED
PREACHING ON THE STREETS OF
TAMPA.
>> THE SALOON KEEPER THREW ME
OUT INTO A DITCH AND TOLD ME
NEVER TO COME BACK.
>> Bret: GRAHAM RECEIVED A
WARMER RECEPTION FROM RUTH BELL.
THEY MARRIED IN 1943.
IS THERE FAMILY GREW, STARTED
HIS MINISTRY.
>> PROBLEMS OF SIN THAT CANNOT
RESOLVE OUTSIDE THE PERSON OF
OUR LORD JESUS CHRIST.
>> Bret: A 1949 CALIFORNIA
TENT REVIVAL DREW NATIONAL
ATTENTION.
>> ISRAEL DID NOT OBEY THE VOICE
OF GOD.
ISRAEL WANDERED FURTHER AND
FURTHER FROM GOD.
>> Bret: CROWDS BEGAN FILLING
STADIUMS, COMING TO HEAR A
SPIRITED NEW MESSAGE ABOUT
JESUS CHRIST AND HIS HEAVENLY
FATHER.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT GOD.
>> Bret: GRAHAM BECAME A
CONFIDENT OF PRESIDENTS AND
OFFERED SPIRITUAL GUIDANCE AT
SEVEN INAUGURATION'S.
ALTHOUGH HE WAS ASKED MANY TIMES
TO RUN FOR OFFICE, GRAHAM SAID
HE WAS NEVER TEMPTED.
HE JUST WANTED TO PREACH THE
WHICH HE DID, INTO HIS 80s.
>> I HAVE NO PLANS TO RETIRE.
THE LORD MAY HAVE PLANS.
>> Bret: PARKINSON'S DISEASE
SLOWED HIM DOWN.
>> I THINK GOD HAS SENT IT TO ME
AT THIS AGE TO SHOW ME THAT I AM
TOTALLY DEPENDENT ON HIM.
>> Bret: HIS MINISTRY HAS BEEN
PASSED ONTO HIS DAUGHTER AN END
SON FRANKLIN, WHO SPOKE WITH US
DURING THE 26 TEAM ELECTION
ABOUT HIS FATHER'S IMPACT.
WHAT WOULD YOUR DAD SAY ABOUT
THE CURRENT STATE OF AFFAIRS
POLITICALLY IN THE COUNTRY?
>> MY FATHER IS NOT ONLY SAD.
I THINK HE'S -- DISCOURAGED IS
PROBABLY A BETTER WORD.
HE IS DISCOURAGED WHEN HE SEES
HOW FAR WE HAVE FALLEN SO
QUICKLY AND HOW QUICKLY OUR
NATION AND POLITICIANS HAVE
TURNED AGAINST GOD.
>> Bret: WHAT STARTED IN A
TENT SO MANY DECADES AGO HAS
TURNED INTO THE LARGEST MINISTRY
IN WORLD HISTORY, A MULTIMEDIA
INNOVATOR INTO THE DIGITAL AGE.
BILLY GRAHAM'S LEGACY LIVES ON
WITH A SIMPLE ENDURING MESSAGE.
>> IF YOU REMEMBER NOTHING THAT
I STAY TONIGHT EXCEPT ONE THING
I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER.